>>TOGH
QU OF PRTI
TIMAYBINCEAND HOEAKER ER IT.E RR
ON THEIR
REWH H
DAY.
THEY'RE REFUSINGO SERV
DEMOCRATIC CONTROLLE
,
WELL, 'S THEIR
BOSS, MITY LEADER KEVIRTHY.
EDP  THEIR COITY
ON THE  CTT
WASATTO THEY LI CHOSE
TO S. I THINK IT'S CL
OTRANS TO BIPARTS TTHE CONSTITT
>> SHE S JE OF T
THE NEW REPUBLICANS TO SUPPORT N
IN THE SENATE.
SHE WAS ONE WHO VOTED TO THE
PRESIDENT, WAS STRIPPED OFERSHIO
CAUST ER H TIES WITH A  PUING
G
NIC ROBLEM.
RE
E HOUSSIGHT, AND G THIHOMELACURY
GRESSMAN MATETZ?
ECON  HIM BOU
POSITIONS?
T
THE CONSPIRAS AN
ASSIGNMENTS BUT BYEM
AFTER KEVIN McCARTHYTAKE ANYCTTE
ACCOUNTABLE.
BECAUSE WHETHE, CRAZIES ET FEDET
FEER PTY.
T PRIORITY.
, S RY ON TOPO IT'S
NOINcCS
ALL SECT COMMITTEE.
>> EBOUGHTIL
CLINTON WAS UNATRI TOGR COELT
COMMITTEE. NUMBE
DEMOCRATIC  LE
RE CHAIRMA THE
INTELLIGENCE COMEE AND A MB OT
WANT NOTNGO  WITH.
CH DO YOU THINK
SAKEN IS
LAWMS G ON A  COMMIO INVESTIGAT
PEOPLE OACE ON'T STRIP
LASER CONSPIRACIES, ALLIANCES
WITHHIMASTWHAY?
IS TO DO WHATEVER DONALD TRUMP T
TELLS HIM TO DMP DOESN'T WUND J
DIDN'T WANTSO MY OPMMISSIS McC
AND NOW THE SELECT COMMITTEE IOR
JOB NONETHELESS  DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSE OBJECTE REPORT OFO H
SIXTH, WHYO  MT Y MAKE RECOMN
PIURE.
>> WHAT HAPPEN IF NO OTHER
PU WHAT
THEN?
FORWARD.
TH
COON THAT WAS EVEN FIVMOCRATS,
ON THEIR OWNWOD RE THAT,
JUST NOT WILNG .
FORCE THEM TO DO
THEIR DUTY AD THEIR OATH.
WE CAN OY LD
UNPROTECTED US WON'T  JT OF SUB
PSD HE WOTESLLG FOPRESIDENT TRU.
DO YOU WANT TO SEE THEMEIDENT T
PROBE?NAED AS  O
I THINK, POSTPONIN
D OFE FULL
NOT JUST WITBUT OU TO
SCE OF THE VESTIGATION AND OU.
TO DEC WITNESSES AREST IMPORTANE
WE'RE STILL
JU GETTINGWA>> KEVIN M ALSO
THINK SOME PEOPLE ARE WOND
THE CALLED TO
YOU'RE NLE
RESPONDING SUBPOENAS.
WHAT HAPPENSN? WT
BRIDGE, I GUESS, WHEN WE GET TO
IT.ANISMS THAT WE
HAVE TO ENFOBPS
T AS WE SA THE MN TION WHICH TOR
IN FT,TECT DY.
BPOENAWEON TY LDACCELERATE ENFO
BUT IN THEEV MAKE REFORME GOING
SURE WGETHE NEED
HIT
CTLY WS
T WHAT ENNGHO WERE THAYBE
FOR DURING THERECTION?
>> WELL, I THINKS
BE VERPOANE GET A FULL BODY OF D
AND I DONT TO
US.T DIREC T
OF E DAY THERE O DISCUSTH
SHOULD BE NOCOWSULD INVESTIGATED
TRAGEDY,HERE
WASN'T A MORE ROBUST RNSNG THE T
HI THENGSS ETHER THEY'RE
NAME IT.
SO WE WANT THIS TOE
HENSIVE.O  OBJECTIVE
WE'RE GO D TO